[Music]
my name is i run the family business
here
the zinc stutterhoof which is located in
the rhineland
in germany more precisely in rama's
occasion it's located between aachen and
cologne
we run an arable farm here with a focus
on industrial potato cultivation
for the production of french fries and
chips
we also cultivate cereals winter wheat
sugar beet
winter rape and carrots
[Music]
helps me to carry out plant protection
and fertilization tasks
in a targeted and precise manner for my
large number of fields and crops
when i open up the program salvia gives
me a plant protection recommendation
for example in winter wheat i select
products in the program
and i can create plant protection tasks
or application maps
i select a plant protection product for
example the honorary treatment
specify a water application rate
specify an application rate of the
product a maximum
application rate and the program helps
me to supply the zones in the area that
have a high crop density
with more plant protection product and
to supply zones with a lower crop
density with less plant protection
products
application maps are created via
satellite images which are available for
me
[Music]
i select them and i can change them if
the proposed values do not suit for me
these maps are saved in savio and then i
can send these maps to the aggro router
[Music]
the employee can use the myamma router
app to receive the data from the agra
rooter
and transfer it via wireless lan to the
amatron 4 terminal
the application map is now on the
amatron 4 and the driver can take a look
at the map
and use it in the field immediately
[Music]
when the tasks are finished on the field
the driver can send the as applied map
back to the aggro router
this as applied map can be picked up by
me from the agra router in the office
and i can use it in my farm management
software
[Music]